but I mean this this also seems quite  simple and uh good enough I mean if  white can't do anything in the Rook at  night then black is just going to win  now I mean so White's got to try to use  the rook and the Knight  to coordinate but you can't actually you  can't actually get anything going with  those two pieces here uh the black king  can always step forwards if it's checked  and uh there's there's nothing here at  all and have a couple of checks but  that's it  32 attacking pieces I have a feeling  well no I'm not I have a feeling black  is actually threatening to give a deadly  check mating threats getting very close  to that you think I mean like  you know what yeah there it is he  resigns our generic I see super tough  start to the final day a loss means he  now has to win two games do you have any  hopes of winning what a great game by  Magnus Carlson so here is today's Lisa  vetta learning point